대신, 이 경우 f(x)의 최솟값은 컷이 통과하는 엣지 수가
최대일 때가 될 거예요. 이 문제를 최소화 문제로 표현하는 이유는, 나중에 이걸 에너지
최소화 문제, 즉 바닥 상태 찾기로 매핑할 수 있기 때문이에요. 이게 바로 양자 컴퓨터가 자연스럽게 정말 잘하는 거거든요.
하지만 아직 양자 컴퓨팅과 관련된 건 아무것도 없다는 걸 기억하세요. 이 문제를 양자 컴퓨터가
이해할 수 있는 형태로 다시 표현해야 해요. 이제 본격적으로 작업을 시작할 준비가 됐어요.
첫 번째 단계는 문제를 양자 circuit에 매핑하는 거예요. 방금 그린 그래프에서
양자 circuit으로 어떻게 가는지 잘 안 보일 수 있지만, 천천히 살펴봐요. QAOA를 이용해
Max Cut 문제를 풀려고 한다는 걸 기억하세요. QAOA 알고리즘에서 최종적으로 원하는 건 연산자,
즉 문제의 비용 함수를 나타내는 데 사용될 해밀토니안과, 파라미터화된
circuit인 ansatz, 즉 시험 상태예요. 문제의 해에 대한 추측이나 후보가 되는 양자 상태를 나타내는 데 사용되는 거죠.
이 후보 상태들에서 샘플링한 다음,
비용 함수로 평가할 수 있어요. 이 경우 비용 함수는 f(x)인데, 이걸
양자 컴퓨터에 친숙한 방식으로 표현해야 해요. 이를 위해 일련의 수학적
변환을 활용해서 f(x)를 에너지 함수인 해밀토니안으로 표현할 거예요. 이 과정의
첫 번째 단계는 f(x)의 최소화 문제를 이차 비제약 이진 최적화
문제, 줄여서 QUBO로 표현하는 거예요. QUBO는 이런 조합 최적화 문제를 표현하는 일반적인 방법이에요.
여기서 Q는 실수로 이루어진 N×N 행렬이고, N은
그래프의 노드 수에 해당해요. 이 예시에서는 5개고요. X는 초기
공식의 이진 변수 벡터와 같아요. QAOA 알고리즘을 효과적으로 실행하려면, 최적화 문제를
해밀토니안 형태로 표현해야 해요. 해밀토니안은 시스템의 총 에너지를 나타내는 수학적 연산자예요. 구체적으로
바닥 상태 에너지, 즉 최소 고유값이
그래프 g에서 최대 컷 수를 인코딩하는 함수의 최솟값에 대응하는 비용 함수 해밀토니안을 만들고 싶어요.
이 해밀토니안을 구하면, 최적화 문제를 푸는 데 필요한 건 양자 컴퓨터에서 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태를 준비하는 것뿐이에요.
그러면 이 상태에서 샘플링하면 높은 확률로 f(x) 최소화의 해를 얻을 수 있어요. 알고 보면
운이 좋게도 QUBO 문제는 물리학에서 가장 유명하고 널리 쓰이는 해밀토니안 중 하나인
이징 해밀토니안과 매우 밀접하게 관련되어 있고 계산적으로 동등해요. QUBO 문제를
이징 해밀토니안으로 쓰려면 실제로 간단한 변수 변환만 하면 돼요.
불리언 변수 0과 1에서 스핀 변수 -1과 1로 바꾸는 거예요. 이 단계는
간단해요. 관심 있으신 분들을 위해 첨부된 노트북의 부록에 더 자세히 나와 있어요. 결국, 이 QUBO
표현의 최소화는 이 표현의 최소화와 같아요. 조금 다시 써보면
비용 함수 해밀토니안이 나와요. 이 표현의 최솟값이 바닥 상태를 나타내고, Z는
파울리 Z 연산자가 되며 b는 실수 스칼라 계수가 돼요. 해밀토니안을 구했으니,
두 개의 국소 ZZ 파울리 연산자로 쉽게 다시 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 양자 circuit에서 두 개의 큐빅 gate로
쉽게 변환돼요. 어떻게 하는지는 관련 노트북을 참고하세요. 출력은
여기 이 줄로 주어져요. 우리 예시에서는
여섯 개의 객체, 즉 파울리 문자열이 있어요. 각각이 그래프의 엣지 하나를 나타내기 때문이에요. 문자열의 길이는 노드 수와 같아요.
즉, IIIZZ는 5개의 노드를 나타내고, 문자열은
엣지에 포함된 노드의 인덱스 위치를 제외한 모든 위치에 항등원으로 구성돼요. 해당 위치엔 Z 항이 들어가죠. Qiskit에서
qubit을 나타내는 비트 문자열은 역순으로 인덱싱돼요. 예를 들어, 노드 0과 1 사이의 엣지는
IIIZZ로 인코딩돼요. 파울리 형태로 쓴 해밀토니안으로 양자 circuit을 구성할 준비가 됐어요.
이 양자 circuit은 양자 컴퓨터에서 좋은 해를 샘플링하는 데 도움을 줄 거예요. QAOA 알고리즘은
단열 정리에서 영감을 받았어요. 시간 의존적 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태에서 시작하고
해밀토니안이 충분히 천천히 진화하면 충분한 시간이 주어졌을 때 최종 상태가
최종 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태가 된다는 거예요. QAOA는 양자
단열 알고리즘의 이산 트로터 버전으로 생각할 수 있어요. 각 트로터 스텝이 P라고 부를 레이어를 나타내죠.
한 상태에서 다른 상태로 진화하는 대신, P의 각 레이어에서 비용
함수 해밀토니안과 잠시 후 더 자세히 이야기할 믹서 해밀토니안 사이를 왔다 갔다 해요. 제가 강조하고 싶은 점은
QAOA가 양자 단열 알고리즘보다 빠르다는 장점이 있지만, 최적해가 아닌 근사해를 반환한다는 거예요.
레이어 수가 무한대로 가는 극한에서 QAOA는 단열
경우에 수렴해요. 하지만 물론 이건 계산 비용이 매우 많이 들죠. 양자 circuit을 만들기 위해
gamma와 beta로 파라미터화된 교대 연산자를 적용할 거예요.
이게 시간 진화의 이산화를 나타낼 거예요. 다시 정리하면, QAOA circuit의 세 가지 주요 부분은
첫째, 회색으로 표시된 초기 시험 상태로, 이게
단열 진화의 믹서 바닥 상태예요. 모든 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 적용해서 만들죠. 둘째,
이미 갖고 있는 진한 보라색의 비용 함수 진화, 그리고 셋째, 아직 논의하지 않은
연한 보라색의 믹서 해밀토니안 아래의 진화예요. 시작 해밀토니안을
믹서라고 부르는 이유는 그 바닥 상태가 관심 있는 모든 가능한 비트 문자열의 중첩이기 때문이에요.
즉, 시작부터 모든 가능한 해의 혼합을 강제하는 거죠. 믹서 해밀토니안은 그래프의 각 노드에 대한
파울리 X 연산의 단순한 합이에요. Qiskit은 원하면 다른 커스텀 믹서 연산자를 사용하게 해주지만,
이 경우엔 표준 것을 쓸 거예요. 다시 보면, Qiskit 덕분에 많은 작업이
자동으로 처리돼서 믹서 해밀토니안과 시작 상태를 만드는 게 간단해져요. 우리가 해야 했던 작업은